so they shot it down it was flying over
America for a few days yeah right move
or brown move to shoot it down yeah
come on come on bro Ben shot that [__]
down yeah Ben shot it down right move or
do you think they left it up there to
let everyone know hey China's a bad guy
and then shot it down while everyone was
watching
I mean that's an acceptable reason maybe
we were trying to extract as much
information because we knew that [__]
would get damaged on the way down but
what information we have to extract our
own
[Laughter]
that's an interesting point you're like
okay what's connected to them what is
fine on us yes I know what his point is
his point is like they spying on us so
we just gonna learn the [__] we already
know about us yeah we want to know what
they know about us they should then we
can get into all their stuff and find
out information oh didn't think about
that you didn't think about that yeah
yeah
no Chinese computer
this is like the third time they hacked
us they didn't hackers they was flying
them but they packed us before so we
ain't hacking anything like this like
70s 90s bro bro bro they flew a balloon
they had this before Titanic came out
son that's not a hack old they didn't
hack us they've been hacked us
couple times so we took out Bruce Lee
this is the first time we took real
action we got that get back
and Brandon Lee
barely think about it don't fall make
your kids don't grow up
they do that bro that is thanks and Fofo
is the p-h-o-p-h-o
um
listen listen but no you were you were
saying your little [__] what was you
saying
why it's so hard for China bro I hate
China I don't like China we need a beef
for China wait wait so you're not gonna
slide on China
oh okay make sure son I'm about that
life all right let me see your slot
yo
are you ready
I don't know let me see yours let me see
yours there's a heck in it yeah
mad choppy mad choppy it's supposed to
be white a White Guy created it uh
that's a good point Chris Tucker
no
where you been bro
no when you're on the Pod when I slide
when I did the [__] Kodak Black [__]
that's what I was like what was this
yeah yo you're the whitest [__]
white bro that's why I don't get the
what is the Chinese water balloon can
actually collect data wise floating
above America it's above Montana like I
don't get what it was actually where do
you think we keep our nukes yeah Mark
but what can they not see from like
everything else they trying to see if
they pointed to them yeah they don't
know
we might go around the other side
that's how them [__] got here
probably
[Laughter]
you know what year it is in the Chinese
three year oh
no
do you know what year it is Bonnie I
think
your money no oh bunny no no not like
Bunny's one of them do you know what
year it is I don't rabbit I think it's
the year the rat right
come on man
well I think it is actually do you know
what it is come on bro why are you doing
that yeah
that [__] is [__] super racist yeah
why you do that that is super we're
having fun here who is it raises against
come on bro you know who's racist
against come on man's who that gigantic
fat [__] titted North Korean won a
podcast in a week
that's who it's racist against oh
[__] bro did you look it up how long
does it take it's so hard to tell it's a
rabbit I was right see of course you're
right you're in the [__] middle of it
you didn't see them
bouncing around for checking the rent
laughs
you're crazy shut up top three top three
favorite Rabbits go oh uh Bunny Bugs
okay guys come easy what Roger bugs
number one bro stop it I was thinking
that vibrator joint yeah exactly yeah
that was probably number one Energizer
Energizer fire B rabbit B rabbit I think
the best rap also fire
but anyway yeah it's a year of the
rabbit stuff what was why'd you ask that
dumb question laughs
oh man [__] you Mario
Bros
this [__] thought we were
talking about Chris Tucker
he was like this do you remember the
whole convo I didn't listen to the
lyrics I just saw you dancing that's it
that's the first time in my life I heard
super Gremlins when you played on that
video damn bro I ain't listening to it
no you don't watch bro you cool as hell
bro
come back now you the coolest guy
not listening to it are you singing
along to it oh no no if we're debating
whether I look cool or not okay we end
it together is all I'm saying yeah yeah
no no you're cool
I'm not cool no you might be cool no
that's life no it might be cooler than
me with that slide no you got got off
white on you cool ass guy
oh that's true you are cool
that's true you're a cool ass guy you
have the jacket my wife got me three
years ago nah don't try to do this yo
you're cool as hell bro vintage vintage
you got vintage that's a good point I'm
very cool you are look at all look at
this [__] down to the shoes yeah I did
come on bro
you are cool bro hey dude you're a cool
[__] dude I pulled my hip a
little bit doing that just now that's
cool though that's cool bro
no do not watch you are the you were the
coolest guy in the room oh thanks man
hey thanks man son you are cool hey
thanks guys
that's awesome
I'm a cool yeah if we call him cool or
wash it's still not funny either way I
don't know I'm trying to find the right
way